okay so the Last of Us TV show takes us
somewhere that we never really saw in
the game in that we woke up playing as
Sarah on the night of the outbreak and
after her death we picked up his gel 20
years later however a TV show can take
us into noon interesting places because
it's not as focused on making sure the
players engaged typically in a game you
tend to keep things centered around one
character so that the player feels like
they're experiencing things through them
and they very much imprint on that one
person it's why so many games had silent
protagonists back in the day and it's a
technique that tends to work when you're
playing a video game what about TV shows
can do things differently not not like
that Halo not like that anyway TV shows
can do things differently and that's
where the last of us has taken the
opportunity to show us flashbacks to
years before the outbreak days prior and
then right after the world just
collapsed throughout this video I'm
going to be discussing the three key
scenes in The Last of Us that take us
back to the past and really make this
show infinitely more terrifying if you
enjoy the video please hit the a thumbs
up button make sure you subscribe for
Last of Us breakdowns every week until
we've milked the entire thing dry anyway
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so the first two scenes are very
much act as bookends of each other in
the first we have a scientist theorizing
how cordyceps could lead to the end of
the world and the second one deals with
a scientists realizing that the end is
now upon us it's very much set of the
threat of the infected and how we will
lose as a species because of it however
the third one cements that there's more
facets to it and instead it shows that
Humanity will also have a hand in this
too we are our own worst enemies and the
fact this third flashback was included
is very important to letting us know who
the true enemy is in all of this I know
it's cliche to be like humanity is the
Real Enemy but there's a reason that
this cliche is there in the first place
and it's not because we're good at
having several conversations things are
often done out of fear and we'll discuss
why the soldiers could have killed those
people later on and the fear that drove
them to it however we have to discuss
the first scene first and we pick up in
1968 decades before the cordyceps
outbreak here we catch something a
little close to home as we initially see
the topic of conversation being an
influenza pandemic we've just lived
through a big one and like the scientist
says we always find a way out of it
eventually John Hannah seems common
collected throughout this and though
it's a struggle we've seen ourselves
that there is light at the end of the
tunnel when it comes to things like this
how about when the subject changes to
fungi the mood drops and there's a far
more Bleak Outlook than the optimistic
view he's just shared rattling off a
chilling monologue he hammers home the
idea that there's absolutely no cure and
in all eventualities that we lose this
is very much the case in what follows as
well we watch the outbreak happen from
Sarah's point of view and killing her
off shows just how Bleak the entire
thing is now I must admit every time a
TV show a movie kills off a kid I'm like
you know what I respect that and it's
for a good reason too Hollywood is
heavily sanitized a lot of the time and
it must take a lot of back and forth
with the studio to be like them kids
Sarah's death very much cements this
idea that it's a lose-lose situation and
there's not going to be some big happy
outcome to this it's a necessary move to
take to show us that the scientist was
indeed right and when soldiers are out
here shooting innocent fathers and
daughters then you know Humanity has
lost its way a bit now this is
immediately followed up by a scene with
another child's death and though it was
necessary to kill him you see exactly
why the scientist was so Doom and Gloom
Joel's emotionless face says it all as
they dump their body on the fire and it
sums up just How Far We've Fallen
episode 2 has us going to a burata when
I drop my episode 2 breakdown I did get
some comments saying that Abu actually
means misses but they should have put
that in the subtitles mate how was I
supposed to know I'm a YouTuber I'm a
[__] I don't know anyway we see her
being brought in by the military to
inspect a corpse infected by the
cordyceps it's very by the book and
though she's alarmed initially by being
brought in the situation seems to calm
down once the military man reassures her
in the car after discovering the
cordyceps in the subject's mouth though
things change and fear washes over her
in the back room she instructs him to
bomb the city and it Hammer's home just
how dire the situation is knowing it
could get out she'd rather destroy the
entirety of Jakarta in the hopes of at
least quarantining it and we know that
several cities adopted this strategy too
however as we learn here it also got
into the food supply and this is how it
managed to spread so fast I always
wondered how the infected managed to get
on board airplanes and bring them
crashing down but if it was in those
delicious delicious in-flight meals then
you can see how it will cause a problem
Mrs Ratner realizes how dire the
situation is and being someone who
studied the fungus all her life she sees
that there's nowhere to save the rest of
the world Beyond destroying her own she
wishes to be with her family for the
final few hours she potentially has and
this is when we realize how Bleak things
are she's very much accepted how
inevitable the downfall of humanity is
and is almost acting as if she's on her
deathbed and wanting to say her goodbyes
it's a beautifully settled performance
that further shows how far Humanity has
its back against the wall and in
desperate times we will do Despicable
things when wandering along the road on
the way to Lincoln we see as Jill and
Ellie come across bodies that have been
murdered by soldiers similar to Joel and
Sarah we see a parent and child with a
Target and on the opposite side of this
we get a flashback in which we watch the
paired boarding a military truck in
order to evacuate the town they think
they're being led to safety and as for
paranoid is Belle was he was in fact
right hashtag bill was right now why did
the humans execute the survivors well we
don't know exactly why but the reason
was likely down a fear Joel theorizes
that they reached the quarantine Zone
and that there probably wasn't enough
rooms other soldiers then killed them
now I think the fear here is twofold
with them potentially having several
reasons that made them do what they did
the first is that they were going to be
turned away and thus they'd end up
roaming the Wilderness and likely
getting infected this would lead to
there being more people to fight and
like Mrs Ratner said it's safe for the
murder than risk the infection spreading
now the second reason I think is that
the soldiers worry that these people
could form their own group and that they
would overthrow them as we experience
the last of us we come across several
factions like that who ended up storming
Federer and then replacing them the
soldiers themselves were murdered and
squatting a group of people could lead
to several deaths on their side again
it's this idea of fear and knowing what
humanity is capable of that pushes them
to do it we themselves that others could
kill them they strike first and this
paranoia thing is also very much at the
heart of why Humanity collapsed the
cordyceps are very much the Catalyst
that will cause us to fight amongst
ourselves because the lack of resources
will push us into that position as the
scientist theorizes in episode 1 we lose
and it's because of a number of factors
not only does the world come to a halt
because of them but the survivors Left
Behind will do whatever they can to stay
alive and get what they want that's very
much the message at the heart of The
Last of Us and though I don't want to
get into spoilers coming down the line
that theme plays off down the road there
are those Among Us who would rather Doom
everyone else and give up what they have
and in many ways it's what's at the
heart of the show that's why the series
is so terrifying because you know though
it's it's not gonna happen well I hope
not there is a chance that it could or a
situation like this that will pit us
against ourselves as I said we are our
own worst enemies and facing off against
each other we'll bring the whole thing
crashing down and that wraps up the
video and obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on those scenes what you
took from them and if you agree or
disagree with me comment below and let
me know and just to let you know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away wakanda forever the three
subscribers on the 15th of February all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so that to you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of episode 3
which will be linked on screen right now
got tons of Easter eggs in it lots of
things to talk about and definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for sticking through the video
I've been poor let's see in the next one
take care peace
[Music]